[MUSIC]
It's late 2008 and I'm in Kurdistan, Iraq
for a political science field trip.
We're driving on a long drive back to the
capital one afternoon
when we stop to stretch our legs at the
base of a gently sloping grassy hill.
And as I get out of the bus, I look around
to see
if there's a good spot to have that
granola bar I've been saving.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And something catches my eye.
Oozing out from under the rocks on the
hill are several foot wide streams
of a thick, brown, mud-like substance.
And as I approach it to take a closer
look, our guide, as if he's read my mind,
shouts, don't eat that!
That's oil.
My first reaction?
Disgust.
I was a student of environmental risk,
active in international climate change
conferences.
I knew for a fact that oil was bad.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But as I stared at this foreign brown
substance, fascination took over.
Isn't oil black?
What was it doing here?
Had an accident happened?
Seeing this natural oil seep made me
realize that I was completely out of touch
with oil, and from this moment forward,
oil, something that had seemed so
clearly black and white to me took on many
shades of well, brown.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Now think back to the first time that
you saw oil.
I bet that it was in a leak of some sort
and that it was bad news.
It might have been motor oil, dripping out
from under your car.
More likely though, it was on the news.
Oil spilling out the side of a tanker.
It's downright devastating what oil can do
to the environment isn't it?
Those images of blackened beaches,
wildlife drenched in the stuff, and
battling to breathe through it.
I was horrified to see how in Nigeria,
forests, rivers,
livelihoods of thousands have been
poisoned by leaks in over 4,000 miles of
pipelines crisscrossing the Niger Delta.
But perhaps freshest in our minds is the
BP oil spill from 2010 that sent over 3.2
million barrels gushing out into the Gulf
of Mexico over the period of three months.
Now 3.2 million barrels, that's 130
million gallons.
I'm gonna try and put that in perspective.
That's enough for you guys seated in the
back two rows
to get three Starbucks grandes everyday
for the rest of your long lives.
And pass that gift card down for 1,000
generations.
That's a lot, that a more bit a lot of
coffee.
Now, fast forward a few years, and
the student of environmental risk is now a
consultant.
>> [LAUGH] ,.
>> Often, often for the oil and gas
industry.
Now in the eyes of many Californians and
certainly many students here working with
or for big oil is considered the single
most uncoolest job you could have.
It's really the antithesis to being the
coveted tech entrepreneur but
it's not just uncool.
It's seen as deplorable.
Total strangers will take it upon
themselves to educate me about my
malevolence and that of my colleagues.
Well meaning friends and family will say
is that ethical?
Shouldn't we get you out of there?
As if I need rescuing because I've clearly
forgotten
to factor in morality into my daily
decisions.
And on the one hand, I really do
appreciate the honesty.
But on the other, these comments sting
every time.
Why?
Because it's hypocrisy, and lacks nuance
where nuance is due.
You see on a personal level, the 130
million gallons that spilled out
during the BP oil spill, the thousand
generations worth of Starbucks, is a lot.
And certainly the destructive power of
that amount of oil is severe.
But from the perspective of consumption,
what spilled out over three months
is only an eighth of what we consume in a
day in the US.
An eighth.
And it's not your neighbors, it's us, you
and I, who are the consumers.
And as consumers our thirst for
oil is insatiable even when we see the
images on TV.
But, we don't like to think of ourselves
as consumers, so oil remains black to us.
But imagine a world without oil in it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There'd be no asphalt.
Some fertilizers wouldn't exist.
We'd have no gasoline.
No jet fuel.
And that's already a stretch of the
imagination.
Now try to imagine a world without
plastics.
Everything from toothbrushes to television
screens has either oil or
gas as the critical input in its
production process.
For me a world without oil would probably
be a lot like the late 1800s.
When oil was this new thing that could
make so much happen, much like smartphones
are now actually, and smartphones driven
by arguably the John D.
Rockefeller of our times, Steve Jobs,
have revolutionized the way we organize
ourselves and communicate with each other.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Certainly I am very thankful for my i,
iPhone,
and I'm very dependent on it.
But getting a phone that's in the hands of
every person on the planet has a price.
There are environmental issues associated
with the extraction of
the minerals required.
And if it's true that Apple's manufacturer
had to hang
nets below its laborer's dorms to prevent
them from committing suicide,
that doesn't attest to the great labor
conditions in the electronics industry.
But are we disgusted when we see the new
iPhone?
No.
In fact, if we were to meet someone from
Apple at a cocktail party,
we'd say something along the lines of, oh,
Apple is it?
I'm big user of Apple products, myself.
But, we never say oh, Exxon is it, I'm a
big user of oil products, myself.
>> [LAUGH].
>> My point is, rarely is anything that
truly rocks the foundation of society,
like oil, like smartphones, all good or
all bad.
And oil, well it's certainly has a dark
side when the risks manifest themselves.
It still fuels the economy, literally.
And it's not so black and white.
For example, I'm pretty sure that you feel
great when you can fill up your car for
under $2.00 a gallon at the pump.
And you're not alone because the average
American household will save
around $750 this year because of the drop
in the oil price, and that's great news.
But, the drop in oil price also endangers
the 9 million jobs in the oil and
gas industry in the US.
That's one in 20 jobs.
A similar contradiction?
Reduce dependence on foreign oil is a
prominent highlight that
any president would love to boast within
their State of the Union.
But in casual conversation, we condemn the
Shell gas boom
that almost single-handedly got us this
independence.
Whose side is she on, you might be
thinking.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I'm rooting for accuracy and fairness
in debate.
In a world of highly polarized media, and
in a community where really taking a
stance is often rewarded,
I invite you to join me on this
uncomfortable space in the middle.
Let's go all out on renewable energy and
energy efficiency, but
also recognize that oil is really doing
something for us in the meantime.
Let's hold the oil industry to really high
standards, but
also respect the people who work in it.
Because the dismissive treatment of oil
just seemed like a form of hypocrisy,
when most of us don't really walk, our
anti-oil talk.
Are we really doing all we can to reduce
our oil footprint?
Things like reducing the amount of plastic
we use and waste.
Fighting for teleconferencing facilities
at our office instead of going for
those much loved business trips.
Taking holidays in Big Sur rather than
flying off to New York for the weekend.
Opting to buy stuff that hasn't been air
freighted in from the other
side of the planet.
Or driving a more efficient car if you
can't get there by bicycle.
But these aren't things that you, know,
not heard before.
For me, the intermediate, more important
step,
is that we need to come to terms with our
complex, difficult and
above all ambiguous relationship with oil,
as individual consumers.
And that is that oil is a substance that
both creates and
destroys many of the things that we hold
dear.
On complex issues such as these my hope is
that we go from visceral black and
white reactions, to responding from a
place of full awareness.
My hope is that the next time you see oil,
you react as an intrigued consumer and see
oil in full color.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]